[Music]
this year we're seeing women come out in
droves to cast ballots in this election
women make up for more than 53 percent
of those who have
already early and absentee voted so far
these numbers are especially huge in key
battleground states
andrea brownleerman of the women's
advocacy group supermajority said
the despair and rage frankly that women
have
when they're facing these impossible
choices about how to put food on the
table
teach the children take care of their
parents juggle child care the day-to-day
is making it really hard to be a woman
in america right now
amen and we're seeing this rage in
hollywood as well
with celebrities canvassing and stumping
for progressive candidates
in this cycle and joining me now is
actress leslie grossman
best known for her work on american
horror stories she's also an outspoken
advocate for voting rights and voter
registration
and i just wanted to talk to you because
you've been doing such amazing ig lives
talking to uh your friends and
colleagues about the upcoming election
and really honing in what i think is the
key to the cycle which is the power of
women and the fact that our rights are
on the line so
you know for you what do you think it is
about
this election and the fact that women
are showing up in massive numbers
well i really related to what you said
about rage zerolina uh i think that all
of us
are on fire and we are all
feeling post-traumatic stress from 2016
we're feeling
burned by what happened we are at home
with our kids we're trying to manage
everything and it's time
to end this nightmare and get back to
some sort of normalcy
and uh we're not going to stop until we
do it and women
are unbelievable multitaskers earlier i
don't have to tell you that we can do a
lot of things at once and we can do a
lot of things very effectively at the
same time
so when we organize look out yeah
absolutely and one of the things that
you took on is voter registration why
did you think
voter registration and just making sure
people were signed up to be able to vote
um was one of the things you wanted to
focus on you know obviously everybody's
doing so many things but voter
registration i feel like that's the core
of the whole thing
is that why you chose to focus on that
absolutely i think there's two things at
play
number one i think you've got people who
are incredibly overwhelmed
life in the united states right now is
very very difficult people are trying to
make it through the day
get food on the table educate their
children and sometimes
the noise of the election feels really
really far away and you're just trying
to get through your days so maybe you're
not really focused
on how important your vote is i think
there's another
factor at play where people feel um
disenfranchised and feel like
my vote doesn't mean anything uh i don't
know that i really like either candidate
what does my vote mean
and those are the people that i really
really want to reach because every
single vote matters we learned that the
hard way in 2016.
we cannot rest on our laurels we cannot
relax i don't i'm not looking at any
polls
there's a reason there's a reason that
the gop
wants to make it difficult for you to
vote and it is because when people vote
republicans lose so
let's not give donald trump any reason
to be able to litigate this in the
courts let's have such a big win that it
is put to bed and this nightmare is
done you're i was just watching your
last guess and you know they're talking
about patience and this could go on for
i mean
i i'm as afraid as my hair is frizzy
right now like i can't take it anymore
so that's what's been my main motivating
factor
yeah i feel like all of us i mean you
spoke of it being a nightmare
and in some ways i feel like but i've
been awake and most nightmares i'm
asleep and then i wake up
and then the nightmare is over but this
feels just like it it got worse it was
child separation
charlottesville and it just kept going
and as a citizen
who just my core value is the equal
treatment of every
human being um this has been a difficult
four years speaking of rage
you've done a number of instagram lives
with your fellow actors about voting
obviously hollywood people are very much
involved
um in uh making sure that people are
turned out
and engaged in this election cycle you
know
why did you choose to step forward and
be outspoken
you know some people choose to stay
quiet and you haven't why
why do you choose to speak well a lot of
people will say
vote right on their social media but
they don't say who to vote for
i think now is the time to draw your
line in the sand and make it very clear
which side you are on this is not a
normal election
and these are not normal people um i
i just think that injustice
is so extreme and i don't think anybody
should leave it up to chance that people
don't really know where you stand
in this election i think it's more
important than ever to say
uh i don't agree to rushing a supreme
court justice in um
who has extreme religious views to help
donald trump
uh you know cheat and steal an election
i don't think that children should be
separated from their parents and that
almost 550 of them can't be reunited
with their families
i don't think that bill barr should act
as donald trump's personal
attorney to settle his personal scores i
would like
to have a government that has some sort
of plan for this awful virus
when you look at countries like south
korea japan
new zealand australia they don't have
special magic that we don't know about
they just have effective leadership and
government that is taking
care of their people we have a
government that's saying let it burn
through the populace and see who lives
and
oh well if you die you die that must be
jesus's will
well that's not how i think well how i
think is we are
smart people who can figure out how to
save as many lives as we possibly can so
these are the things that are on my mind
celina
there's a lot on my mind too all the
time i'm always wanting for people to
follow the science like they're doing in
those other countries so that we can get
through this
crisis and the pandemic leslie grossman
thank you so much and thank you for
your advocacy and also just being
awesome
i love you on american horror story and
i feel like i just did
one of my bucket list items